[Music]
in this video today we shall go back to
king of the monsters and discuss about
the 12
titles that were not seen in the movie
but were noted to have come out and
attacked humanity
at the behest of monster zero as well as
have died
due to some unknown events we have found
images that better describe them and
also locations of where they might be
on this planet and most of them are
hidden and hibernating until the events
of kotm
so subscribe to be a part of the mind
cue family and now
let's get down with this sickness
number one abaddon appearing in the
x-ray screen to be some sort of a rock
titan with insect-like limbs
the name abaddon is actually the hebrew
word for doom
and in greek it's apollon it is also a
biblical fallen angel sometimes the
angel of death and sometimes the angel
of destruction
this titan is discovered in the devil's
tower in wyoming in the united states
the post abaddon was contained in
monarch outpost 77 is a possible
reference to the 1977 toho film
the war in space or the last dinosaur or
possibly even the close encounters of
the third kind
which were also released in 1977 and
features the devil's tower
his name sounds familiar to another one
of godzilla's arch nemesis
hmm who could that be maybe destroyer
number two bunyip another titan that was
discovered in a similar fashion as
abaddon
this one however was hibernating in the
heart of australia
in the is rock formation and obviously
monarch
built an outpost around it the outpost
bundy was contained in
monarch outpost 99 is a possible
reference to the 1999 toho film godzilla
2000
millennium regarding the appearance of
this titan it might say it looks like an
aquatic mammal with giant tusks
somewhat like a hippopotamus or giant
walrus it could be another mammalian
titan like gom and behemoth
but in the monitor screens it is shown
as a serpentine sea horse-like titan
with many frills and tedical like our
growths
number three baphomet discovered in
volubilis in morocco which had ancient
roman ruins and an ancient city
that was lost in time baphomet was found
hibernating beneath the ancient ruins
baphomet was a goat-headed demonic
entity worshiped by the knights templar
in myths but in truth it was a
fabrication to incriminate the templars
as worshipers of a false god
in the screens it is shown that titanos
baffermen had insect-like limbs
with flaps of skin attached to them
which could serve as wings for the titan
the outpost baphomet was contained in
monarch outpost 68
could be a possible reference to the
1968 touhou film destroy all monsters
number 4 leviathan this titan is known
to many as the loch ness monster and was
discovered in the loch ness of scotland
the leviathan had outpost number 49
built around it it is presumably way
bigger than any real world estimates for
the loch ness monster
the leviathan is fully aquatic and can
travel from the lake
to many parts of the world's oceans via
tunnels going through the hollow earth
the world leviathan comes from the
biblical use which means the leviathan
is a giant sea creature created by god
usually described as a serpentine or a
whale
a light creature and is the counterpart
to the land behemoth
in the screens it looks like an octopus
an appearance with only four to six
tentacles however
and they are massive and bulky in size
number five the kraken this titan the
kraken was briefly described in the
novelization of king of the monsters
and it greatly resembles an octopus or a
squid but is much larger with a dense
curving cone of shell that protects its
massive brain
using radiation signatures and biosonic
emissions
monarch had discovered an invisible
hibernating kraken wrapped around the
remains of a nuclear submarine
that had been lost or missing for
decades in the indian ocean
like other octopods kraken can change
the color and patterns of its shell
and skin to become virtually invisible
he can also mimic other states such as
death
by disguising his radiation signature
the monarch outpost a crack in his
container is mentioned to be top secret
but it is in the indian ocean number six
tiamat like abaren and banya tiamat
is discovered hibernating in a massive
rock formation in georgia the united
states
in what is known as stone mountain the
outpost diamond was contained in monarch
outpost 53
as a possible reference to the 1953
warner brothers film
the beast from twenty thousand fathoms
in mythology
she is a primordial goddess of the sea
mating with a god of ground water
to produce younger gods she is the
symbol of chaos and primordial creation
some sources identify her with images of
a serpent
or a dragon with a couple of heads
number 7 sekhmet yet another possible
mammalian titan
sekhmet is said to have or possessed
filing trade something like the sphinx
or a lioness
and also described as a giant lion like
kaiju sekhmet was a warrior
and a healing goddess in ancient
egyptian mythology
a solar and war deity the outpost
segment was contained in monarch outpost
65
it's a possible reference to the 1965
toho film invasion of astro monster
when ghidorah calls all the titans
sekhmet breaks free and begins to hunt
with her new pack
destroying a railway station amongst
other structures in the screens she
looks to be like a centipede with a
multiple limbs and an elongated body
like insect
she might be a mix of a line and a
centipede in appearance
number eight yamata no orochi this titan
was discovered hibernating in mount fuji
in japan
and is said to have multiple heads like
ghidorah yamata no orochi is a snake or
a dragon in japanese legend
that has eight heads and eight tails
which was the same as the touhou kaiju
legendary might have had a deal with
touhou for use of the kaiju
as well but just in limited stock
standing at 300 meters tall when upright
the orochi who appeared in the birth of
japan is one of the tallest monsters
ever to appear in a film produced by
toho
it could be that this titan was in fact
the same one from the birth of japan
i mean the one from most of us could be
the same one from japan the birth of
japan
but of course with a different storyline
and minor changes in appearance
number nine typhon although typhon is a
monstrous and powerful male serpentine
giant in greek mythology
and the father of cilla in the monster
verse however he is a titan that was
discovered hibernating in cambodia
deep under the angkor wat ruins the
outpost iphone was contained in monarch
outpost 92
it's a possible reference to the 1992
touhou film godzilla vs mothra
in the monitor screens however he is
shown to be something
quite different than a serpentine deity
he looks to be almost amorphous
and rock like an appearance with
multiple eyes growing on his body
being so close to the sight of where
mothra is typhoon could have also been a
benevolent titan as well
number 10 quetzalcoatl found hibernating
in the ancient incan ruins of machu
picchu which are found in the
andes mountains of peru kenzel quarrel
is a tyrant that sleeps beneath this
ancient city and was worshipped
as a god by the incans and the south
american peoples of peru
quezon quartal was a feathered serpent
deity in the cultures of pre-columbia
particularly by the aztec and the nahuwa
the outpost castle quarter was contained
in monarch outpost 57
as a reference to the 1957 toho film the
mysterious
and it could possibly mean that this is
yet another flying title of the
monsterverse
number 11. amhuluk this island was
discovered in a very weird rock
formation in mother russia
in the map opener of formations to be
exact in the midst it is described to be
a furry creature with several spots
a pair of horns in its head furless legs
and a body resembling that of a
traditional western dragon
the outpost amhulu was contained in
monarch outpost 66 is a possible
reference to the 1966 toho film
abira horror of the deep it could be
that amhulu was discovered hibernating
in hiding camouflage as one of the tower
rocks for information and emerged when
ghidorah sounded his alpha call
and number 12 mark yeager this is an
aquatic scaly reptilian titan similar to
godzilla
but about the size of a whale she has a
flat face with her nostrils above her
human-like eyes
like some aquatic mammal and her skull
protrudes backwards as a result
shielding her neck from threats in death
mager appears to be burnt with a
skeleton showing a jagged riff running
from her neck to her abdomen
maguiger was killed near the arctic by
an unknown tyrant possibly godzilla
later monarch discovers her frozen
corpse and takes her to their
headquarters
where the male muto the female mutual
and meteor prime were situated to
experiment on them
and with that we come to the end of this
video do like for support and also
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family
as well as smash that notification bell
for regular updates on your phones
when we publish new videos on monsters
kaiju's titans
godzilla vs common dissection videos and
more right here on minecube
take care fam